>>> THIS MORNING, THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINEE FOR GEORGIA
SENATE SEAT HERSCHEL WALKER IS
DENYING A DAILY BEAST REPORT
THAT HE PAID FOR HIS
EX-GIRLFRIEND'S ABORTION MORE
THAN A DECADE AGO.
WALKER IS CURRENTLY RUNNING ON
BANNING ABORTIONS WITH VERY FEW
EXCEPTIONS.
NOW, CNN CANNOT INDEPENDENTLY
CONFIRM THE DAILY BEAST REPORT
WHICH WALKER HAS STRENUOUSLY
DENIED.
CNN'S EVA McKEND IS JOINING US
NOW WITH THIS STORY.
EVA, WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
THIS?
>> BRIANNA, THE FORMER NFL STAR
HAS FACED A LITANY OF
CONTROVERSIES, BUT THIS HAS TO
BE THE MOST EXPLOSIVE TO DATE.
"THE DAILY BEAST" REPORTS THEY
CORROBORATED THE WOMAN'S ACCOUNT
OF WALKER PAYING FOR HER
ABORTION BY REVIEWING A MEDICAL
RECEIPT FROM THE ABORTION CLINIC
AND NOTE CARD WALKER ALLEGEDLY
SENT THE WOMAN AT THE TIME.
THE TABLOID ADDITIONALLY REPORTS
THEY REVIEWED A BANK DEPOSIT
RECEIPT THAT INCLUDED WALKER'S
SIGNATURE HANDWRITING.
WALKER, AN ANTI-ABORTION
HARD-LINER WHO RESISTS
TERMINATING A PREGNANCY IN
INSTANCES OF RAPE, INCEST AND
LIFE OF THE MOTHER, IS FACING A
STEADY DRUMBEAT OF STORIES THAT
CAST DOUBT ON HIS CREDIBILITY.
HE BLASTED IN LATEST STORY AS A
FLATOUT LIE, DENYING WHAT HE
DISMISSED AS DISGUSTING GUTTER
POLITICS IN THE STRONGEST
POSSIBLE TERMS.
TAKE A LISTEN SO HOW HE DEFENDED
HIMSELF ON FOX NEWS LAST NIGHT.
>> IT IS A FLATOUT LIE.
AND NOW YOU KNOW HOW IMPORTANT
DECEIT IS.
DECEIT IS VERY IMPORTANT.
THEY'LL DO ANYTHING TO WIN THIS
SEAT, LIE, BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
MAKE IT ABOUT EVERYTHING ELSE
EXCEPT WHAT THE TRUE PROBLEMS WE
HAVE IN THIS COUNTRY IS,
INFLATION, THE BORDER WOIDE OPE.
CRIME.
THEY DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT --
>> SHORTLY AFTER THE STORY WAS
PUBLISHED, WALKER'S SON
CHRISTIAN, AN OUTSPOKEN
CONSERVATIVE ACTIVIST, TOOK TO
TWITTER TO ATTACK HIS FATHER AND
LEVELED A SERIES OF ACCUSATIONS
AGAINST HIM, ESSENTIALLY
CHARACTERIZING HIM AS A LIAR.
>> ANY SENSE, EVA, OF HOW THIS
FACTORS INTO THE RACE?
>> I THINK IT IS TOO SOON TO
TELL.
I THINK WE'RE ALL STILL
DIGESTING ALL OF THIS.
DEMOCRATS IN GEORGIA APPEAR TO
BE TREADING LIGHTLY FOR NOW.
I REACHED OUT TO MANY SOURCES
AND HAVEN'T HEARD BACK AS YET.
THE NRSC, THE NATIONAL
REPUBLICAN SENATORIAL COMMITTEE,
THEY DEVOTED MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO ELECTING WALKER AND THEY
PRETTY QUICKLY GOT INTO DEFENSE
MODE LAST NIGHT, TELLING ME THAT
THIS IS A DISTRACTION, AND
FIRMLY STANDING BEHIND THEIR
CANDIDATE, ARGUING THEY FEEL AS
THOUGH THEY'RE WINNING THE
CONVERSATION BY TALKING ABOUT
THINGS LIKE INFLATION, AND THAT
DEMOCRATS AND THEIR ALLIES IN
THE MEDIA ARE DEFLECTING.
THE QUESTION, THOUGH, IS NOW IS
WALKER A FIGURE LIKE TRUMP WHO
CAN DO NO WRONG IN THE EYES OF
HIS SUPPORTERS OR DO THE
ACCUMULATION OF THESE STORIES
PROVE TO BE TOO DAMAGING?
WE'RE JUST TWO WEEKS AWAY FROM
EARLY VOTING IN GEORGIA.
>> THE NRSC, THEY'RE STANDING
BEHIND THEIR CANDIDATE, EVA.
ARE THEY STANDING BEHIND HIS
DENIAL?
>> YOU KNOW, THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION, BRIANNA.
THEY SAID -- THEY CHARACTERIZED
THE ALLEGATIONS, THEY SAY THAT
STORIES THAT MAY OR MAY NOT BE
TRUE.
THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT POINT.
THEY ARE NOT OUTRIGHT DENYING
THE CONTENT OF THE STORY.
AND WE'LL JUST HAVE TO SEE IN
THE DAYS AND WEEKS AHEAD IF THAT
IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE A
SUSTAINABLE POSITION.
>> YEAH.
CERTAINLY.
EVA, GREAT REPORT, THANK YOU SO
MUCH
>>.
>>> SO HERE WE ARE WITH FIVE
WEEKS TO GO UNTIL MIDTERMS.
HOW DOES THIS GEORGIA RACE AND
OTHER KEY RACES
POWER?
JOINING US, CHRIS CILLIZZA.
YOU'RE LOOKING AT A HANDFUL OF
KEY RACES THAT COULD CHANGE THE
BALANCE OF POWER IN THE SENATE.
TAKE US THROUGH THIS.
>> I'LL GET TO GEORGIA IN A
MINUTE.
THAT RACE IS ONE OF THEM,
BRIANNA.
FIRST I START WITH WHERE WE ARE
BROADLY.
36 SEATS UP IN THIS ELECTION.
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
THERE ARE 7 MORE REPUBLICAN
SEATS THAN DEMOCRATIC SEATS.
THERE ARE MORE TARGETS FOR
DEMOCRATS THAN REPUBLICANS, BUT
THIS IS THE OTHER PIECE OF MATH
I WANT YOU TO REMEMBER.
DEMOCRATS HAVE A, ONE SEAT,
SHOULD HAVE BEEN A ONE, HAVE A
ONE-SEAT MAJORITY.
OKAY?
TALKING ABOUT VERY NARROW
MARGINS HERE.
LET'S GET TO GEORGIA.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT RACE.
THIS IS RAFAEL WARNOCK ELECTED
IN THAT JANUARY 2021 SPECIAL
ELECTION, AND WALKER.
WALKER'S CAMPAIGN.
THIS IS NOT NEW.
LOTS OF CONTROVERSY HAS FOLLOWED
HERSCHEL WALKER THROUGHOUT HIS
CAMPAIGN, BUT HE STILL IS WITHIN
STRIKING DISTANCE.
EXCUSE ME, STRIKING DISTANCE.
46-41 IS A MANAGEABLE RACE.
THE THING TO REMEMBER ABOUT THIS
TOO.
IF NEITHER CANDIDATE GETS 50% IT
GOES TO A DECEMBER RUNOFF WITH
THE TOP TWO VOTE GETTERS.
THE RACE MIGHT NOT BE OVER IN
NOVEMBER.
IT MIGHT GO TO DECEMBER.
GO THROUGH A FEW OTHER ONES.
PENNSYLVANIA IS PROBABLY THE
RACE MOST PEOPLE ARE FOLLOWING
IT AT ALL, I'VE HEARD.
JOHN FETTERMAN, LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR AGAINST MEMIC OZ, TV
DOCTOR.
A D PLUS 2 RACE.
SORRY, DOCTOR, WROTE ON HIS FACE
THERE.
A D PLUS TWO RACE RIGHT NOW.
THIS HAS MOVED.
FETTERMAN WAS AHEAD BY HIGH
SINGLE DIGITS IN THIS RACE,
REALLY HAD OZ ON THE DEFENSIVE.
NOW FETTERMAN IS STARTING TO
CLOSE A LITTLE.
OZ IS HITTING FETTERMAN ON
CRIME, A COMMON THEME IN THE
SENATE RACE SINCE REPUBLICANS
ARE ATTACKING ON CRIME.
GO TO NEVADA.
THIS IS SORT OF YOUR UNDER THE
RADAR SENATE RACE.
IT'S OUT WEST.
NOT AS MANY PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
IT, BUT LOOK HERE.
THIS IS THE INCUMBENT.
43 FOR THE DEMOCRAT.
ADAM HAPPENED TO UNITED DONALD
TRUMP AND MITCH McCONNELL BEHIND
HIM, AMAZING THING GIVEN WHAT
WE'VE SEEN OVER THE LAST FEW
DAYS, 45.
MOST POLLING HAS THIS RACE
EFFECTIVELY TIED, BUT THESE ARE
THE THREE RACES.
GEORGIA -- VERY CLOSE, AS YOU
CAN SEE.
PENNSYLVANIA -- BASICALLY TIED.
NEVADA -- EFFECTIVELY TIED.
THESE ARE THE TRHREE RACES, I
THINK, WHEN WE GET DOWN TO IT
THE CLOSEST AND DECIDERS OF
WHICH PARTY CONTROLS THE SENATE.
JOHN?
>> THERE ARE THE THREE, BUT IF
YOU WERE TO GO TO FOUR.
IF YOU COULD COUNT HIGHER THAN
THREE, CHRIS WHAT WOULD BE THE
FOURTH SENATE RACE.
>> ONE -- TWO -- SORRY.
TAKE TOO LONG FOR ME TO COUNT TO
FOUR.
GOING TO THIS NEXT SLIDE.
OKAY.
I THINK -- I THINK -- THE NEXT
ONE THERE IS THIS RACE.
WISCONSIN.
RON JOHNSON AGAINST LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR MANDELA BARNES.
JOHNSON PLUS TWO OF LATE IS A
CHANGE AS WELL.
JOHNSON, STOP ME IF YOU'VE HEARD
THIS BEFORE, A LITTLE BROKEN
RECORD, GONE AFTER BARNES ON HIS
CRIME RECORD THINKS HE'S SET ON
CRIME AND MADE UP GROUND.
A SLEEPER RACE, THOUGH?
NEW HAMPSHIRE, TALK A LOT ABOUT,
BECAUSE OF THE CONTROVERSIAL
REPUBLICAN NOMINEE.
OHIO TALK A LOT ABOUT BECAUSE JD
VANCE IS UNDERPERFORMING.
IT'S OHIO.
TRUMP WON BY EIGHT POINTS THERE.
THIS IS THE RACE PEOPLE AREN'T
TALKING ABOUT.
NORTH CAROLINA, TED BUDD, TRUMP
ENDORSED RUNNING AGAINST A WOMAN
NAMED BEASLEY.
CAME OUT TIED.
A STATE TRUMP WON AND ALSO A
STATE BARACK OBAMA WON IN 2008.
KEEP AN EYE ON NORTH CAROLINA
IT'S A LITTLE BIT OUTSIDE OF
THAT IMMEDIATE NARROW -- THIS,
IF WE'RE RANKING, I'M GOING TO
PUT THAT ONE-FOURTH, WISCONSIN,
BUT KEEP AN EYE ON NORTH
CAROLINA.
THAT MIGHT BE THE RACE WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT, BUT A RACE THAT
ACTUALLY WINDS UP BEING A LITTLE
CLOSER THAN MOST PEOPLE EXPECT.
GUYS?
>> WE WILL KEEP OUR EYE ON THAT
AND TO REMIND PEOPLE, YOU HAVE A
IN PODCAST, CHRIS CILLIZZA,
EXPLAINING HOW THE WORLD WOULD
CHANGE WITH TINY SHIFTS IN THE
STATUS QUO.
LISTEN TO THIS WHEREVER YOU GET
YOUR PODCASTS.
CHRIS, THANKS SO MUCH.